[Music]
chuck yeah
so do they have july 4th in england
i mean
the date yes yes of course
that was a brain teaser that i
encountered when i was a kid
you know is there july 4th and of course
there is they just don't celebrate it
all right
so let me tell you how badass the
american colonists were okay if i may
all right okay i'd like to hear we sign
this document
called the declaration of independence
[Music]
and it is
the statement
that we are independent of england but
it is not yet achieved it's not yet
attained
we have to fight a war right okay
and so the war comes to an end
and we create uh the with the
constitution and the constitution gets
ratified we elect the first president
normally
that's when people date the birth of
their country right
and that was
13 years later
but the colonists and we
say we were born the day we say we were
born right
no that's some og stuff right there yeah
i got to give it to you that's uh that's
pretty gangster every other country when
they achieve their independence it's
celebrated on the date that something
was ratified something was agreed upon
or some
victory was won right none of that was
going on on july 4th that's like you go
to the obstetrician you know and uh the
doctor's like uh i think we're going to
induce labor on the 15th and then from
inside the womb you're here yeah that
doesn't work for me
i don't think so yeah i don't think so
man
i'm kind of busy on the 15th
[Laughter]
let me check my schedule
so
so here's some interesting things so we
can ask well why
is it
celebrated with fireworks right we you
know chinese invented fireworks right
okay by the way i don't know how long
the united states has been invoking
fireworks to celebrate the fourth but
once we adopted
the star-spangled banner right as the
national anthem yeah the that is a
description of fireworks except it's war
all right bombs bursting in mid-air
right gabe proved through the night that
the flag was still there and ran par you
know just the words and the the the the
anthemic
uh uh uh musical dimension to it it's
all
it's all fireworks and so
so so and so by the way what it says is
the star-spangled banner is a
commemoration of war right like all of
america
gotta love that wait wait no martin
luther king day that's a peace day i
think we got to think of that as a peace
day
i will think of that as a peace day but
i will also think of it as a
uh
a war on racism
okay what a war that had to be one that
shouldn't have needed to have been
fought in the first place right okay
there you go but no no there's another
there's still a struggle involved okay
well there's another war day
which i forgot to mention it's
thanksgiving that's where families fight
quintessential american war day that's
war day
you know your republican uncle comes in
with your
with you know right with your super
liberal uh you know aunt from the other
side of the family and of course your
your woke cousin has to sit down at the
table and then you you all square off
and you
you you you put out your opposing views
and you argue and you look like you're
gonna kill each other and then you show
that you trust each other by eating food
with the other people who clearly could
have poisoned you
that's how we know we still family
have some more of this slice of pie
exactly
so so fireworks are fascinating because
we like them of course for several
reasons one they make a
an explosion exploding sound by the way
they're in a very serious there's a ptsd
aspect of this there's certain veterans
that cannot hang around uh fireworks
displays because of the explosions and
what that triggers within them so it is
indeed a commemoration of war as any
veteran with ptsd from explosions will
tell you so that's a first sort of side
fact but the
so you have explosions and an explosion
is the physics of an explosion it is
very high temperature
achieved very quickly
in a small volume of air
interesting and what happens when you
heat air
it expands it expands okay normally the
answer to that is oh hot air rises well
why does it rise because it expands and
becomes less dense
and then it rides and floats on the more
dense air so to say that it rises
implicitly admits
that it expanded except the hot air
that's gently heated expands gently and
so there's nothing catastrophic going on
there right but if you have
rapidly heated air
in a small volume
it will create an acoustic so the air
will
expand as fast or faster than sound can
move through it
hole
yes
yes and that makes a shock wave
oh my goodness
so
it starts off as a silent
event well yeah the heat the initial
heating of the air nothing's happened
yet right the air has to expand
as fast or faster than the speed of
sound in the air and then you get a
shock wave point is in fireworks you
want to hear the explosion and so
everything that is a pop or the
concussive
uh sound
is air heating getting heated faster
than sound can move through it so let's
start there so that's where you get the
sounds all right
so then
you get the colors
oh my gosh okay well so pretty
okay so if god didn't want us to have
fireworks he wouldn't have given us all
these beautiful chemicals on the
periodic table
okay because all these chemicals have
electrons
in their outer shells
and if you move electrons up and down
among those shells
they will give you specific wavelengths
of light
right okay
and you find the elements
where when you do this you get an orange
or green or a yellow or blue
and then you package them in such a way
that they become excited
and then when they de-excite they give
you this light it's a beautiful thing
it's it's beautiful
now in addition you can actually just
burn something up there
and
do you know the the coolest of glowing
burning things is red hot
red is the coolest
okay of burning things uh yeah so when i
see red hot chili pepper or something
i'm saying you got some hotter stuff
than that i'd say to myself
astrophysically if you heat it to a
higher temperature it begins to glow
white hot
that's it and heat it even higher it'll
glow blue hot
as welders know the arc the the the
welding arc it's not red
it's blue yeah that's that puppy's blue
and at that blue point it's also giving
you ultraviolet light which is bad for
your eyes so they've got the the
welder's helmets i mean advisors they
know this well just glass welder's glass
exactly anything that you can use
outside of the approved of visual aids
to look at an eclipse a total solar
eclipse oh check
a plus for check don't gold star chuck
you can put gold star on the wall
right now i was gonna say that and chuck
like just led led the party oh by the
way then you have little sparkly things
that burn and take time to burn out
yes okay now if you might have played
with magnesium in in in high school
chemistry of course we had these we had
these magnesium strips trips it's the
best thing in the world to set up this
stuff on fire
in the bunsen burner oh my gosh oh by
the way what's the hottest part of the
bunsen burner uh wait well it's got to
be the blue part it's the blue part
right down in the middle there's a
little sort of oval
you go to the tiny the tip of that oval
is the hottest which is where by the way
you had to stick the strip this is my
point okay
if you're heating things anything you
want to heat up you're going to go to
the blue part part of that flame okay
that's the hottest part of the flame all
right and by the way if you had mixed in
too much oxygen or two i forgot which
way that goes the flame just ends up
yellow yeah right and with the bunsen
burner you can adjust the oxygen mixture
almost like it's got its own carburetor
right you adjust the oxygen mixture
until it's a pure blue flame
bluer right in the middle so you take
take your magnesium strip and put it in
there and it ignites
and then it just burns on its own and
it's bright and it'll burn slowly up the
strip until you burn yourself right um
so and that's a bright uh that was like
a sky blue color if i remember
what color that was but but anyhow you
you know people who are good at this and
know all about it will find all
combinations of things that burn at
different rates at different colors
and the strength of the explosion will
matter
because that's how it tells you how big
how how widespread
the burning bits will will go
right and i think almost everybody's
favorite firework i don't want to speak
for everybody but okay i'll speak for
myself is the chrysanthemum you know the
one where it explodes out and then
it then looks like a willow tree just a
willow tree as as it um
as it descends and continues to sparkle
so
what a beautiful i mean if i had a if i
were a chemist that's that's probably
the job i would want inventing new kinds
of fireworks yeah
see there you go america you need to be
look look how proud you should be in
this country we made war so beautiful
so
and and also with the finale right they
always save the loudest
you know
think about it everything until the
finale is really just preamble right
because you're there for the finale
right
where they said ignite it all you know
by the way macy's used to do this
when my parents were kids from a barge
in the hudson river correct right so
nothing would burn and then one year
a fire broke out on the barge and
ignited all the fireworks and everyone
thought that that was the finale ah
yeah and so they canceled the fireworks
for decades until they figured out can
we do this thing somebody said to him
don't worry this happens to lots of guys
it's okay it happens all the time
right so in my lifetime in my parents
lifetime they had it and they got rid of
it and in my lifetime they resurrected
it and so now we have fireworks once
again in new york city so anyhow my
hat's off to the chemical
are they chemical engineers just
chemical
they're kids who never grew up who
became adults and wanted to play with
explosives and do it in a pretty way
that have uh graced the world all over
uh not just domestically of course but
around the world and there you have it a
little bit of fourth of july fantastic
chuck that's fine that's the end of our
explainer oh
that would be great always good to have
you here happy fourth of july happy
fourth of july to one and all
americans
not the brits yeah that's right screw
you britain
oh by the way real quick we don't have
time for this but uh in trafalgar square
in london yeah that's like one of their
biggest of squares they have lord nelson
up on the top of a
pedestal you know one of their great
military all right
in the corner in the back
in the back of the square
is a statue of george washington
oh
i thought that was looking on
at things and i thought that was
interesting because you know for sure
we sure as hell do not have a statue of
king george the the sick or whatever
what number was he there's no way no no
yeah we are not putting up a statue of
king george and if you look very closely
at that statue of george washington he's
giving the finger to lord nelson
all right as always keep looking up
especially at the fireworks
[Music]